you mentioned getting rid of the
Department of Education a bunch of other
alphabet agencies one of them is the FBI
what is your argument you know this is a
Libertarian audience so you've already
you know you had us at F but what is
your case against dismantling the FBI
and what would you replace it with if
anything yeah so FBI IRS ATF Alcohol
Tobacco Firearms
nuclear Regulatory Commission we've
identified and I'm not doing this glibly
right because you know there's agencies
we can just list the whole thing we've
studied and understood what we're going
to do with each one the Department of
Education should have never existed in
the first place we're shutting that down
the FBI look as long as you're gonna
have federal laws you need a federal law
enforcement apparatus but that's in a
different category as is the IRS as long
as you have taxes which I'm not a big
fan of but as long as you have taxes you
need somebody to collect them so be it
the problem there is slightly different
you have
a cultural Corruption of those
institutions that runs so deep that I
believe it will be impossible to reform
top down or any other way it's part of
the rot of the Beast it is the Leviathan
itself is ossified
and so I think they're the only right
answer is you shut it down and then you
built something skeletal from scratch to
take its place that actually respects
the Constitution rather than viewing it
as an inconvenience and it's the same
FBI that corruptly denied Martin Luther
King Jr in this country a concealed
carry permit that now politicizes
another Direction so if you look at the
area under the curve over the last 60
years this would actually be a
bipartisan consensus it's just that
Republicans and Democrats would have
supported it at different times so I'm
getting a job done that we should have
gotten done 60 years ago it's literally
still the J Edgar Hoover building in
Washington DC that those employees walk
into it's J Edgar Hoover's FBI even
though the guy's long gone and I'll shut
it down could I just return to the the
alphabet agencies for a second there
because for Libertarians another group
that we tend to worry about are the
national security agencies the NSA the
CIA the DHS and talk about lawlessness
um and the kind of you know un the
unwinding we've seen of our foreign
policy in general in terms of you know
both covert and overt operations
overseas totally what is your general
take on kind of that National Security
apparatus and just it is corrupt
National Defense okay it is corrupt it's
fundamentally corrupt and you know I
think I mean even recently you don't
have to look to ancient history for this
I think it is appalling that we have a
media that will focus on the mechanics
of a leak and how to prosecute some
basically kid who leaked some material
and I'm not condoning that but
what about focusing on the substance of
the leak that we actually have troops on
the ground in Ukraine which is in a war
with Russia right without telling the
American people not only without telling
what lying about it right and this has
just been a habitual pattern in our
national security establishment it is
corrupt get rid of do you get rid of the
Pentagon too you built afterwards well
I'm not gonna be glib I mean I've I've
studied the agencies that were that were
we've identified to shut down and I mean
it when I say we will shut them down and
what we and the ones we'll rebuild and
the ones we won't
you know I I have a very I'll certainly
drain the managerial class at the
Pentagon that much I'll go without
saying but I'm I'm not going to just
give you a glib answer I'm not Ron
DeSantis okay I'm not just going to say
something because I think it's going to
impress you and then and then you just
screw it up later what is it here's what
I will say massive reform is needed the
managerial class runs the show at the
Pentagon that much is clear how we go
about draining it that's a beast we're
gonna have to look at how we take on I
think someone I think I'm also going to
send a signal and set some tone here I'm
looking actually you know the campaign
Trail is so busy but I want to make a
trip out to the UK I want to visit
Julian Assange I expect to Pardon Julian
Assange I think the fact that the fact
that Chelsea Manning got a sentence
commuted by President Obama but without
Julian Assange the person who actually
just published the information that was
leaked I just think this is this just
reeks of the rot that is the
administrative police state disguised in
the Garb of Nationals what about uh
people like uh Edward Snowden or Daniel
Hale also are they Patriots or are they
truth tellers or are they treason uh so
I would say I mean I I have a long and
growing pardon list I mean the likes of
Douglas Mackey right who's facing 10
years in prison now for making a meme
about Hillary Clinton supporters on the
internet this is not the country we live
in right so here's where I am on the
store I think I actually actually think
he did do an important national service
I'm thinking through that part Julian
Assange I'm on firm footing on because
he's a journalist he's somebody who
literally posted
the stuff he was given that's just how
the free press works this is a selective
prosecution you know the thing with
Snowden is part of what might make it
honorable is he took the risk and and
the knowing risk of actually
you know he violated the law right and
so I believe in the rule of law that's a
tougher case for me and so I'm thinking
through that but that's not something
I'm going to make a commitment on right
now but Julian Assange I I have thought
through and made a commitment on that
shouldn't it exactly well with Assange
you know what he is what they're going
have gone after him for posting or
working with uh Chelsea Manning to post
where these videos from uh you know uh
military operations in Afghanistan uh
basically uh one involved the kind of
gunning down of a photojournalist
I'm curious you know as a you you say
you're continuing the America First
agenda and part of that what Trump shook
up within the Republican party was
foreign policy and rethinking the role
of American Military might where we
should and shouldn't be in the world
what are your thoughts on American
foreign policy interventionism I think
it has been disastrously expansive and I
think that we should actually have
leaders who are able to lead with
authority diplomatically using our
economic might and the backstop of
military strength yes but economic might
is part of it's part of what we've also
lost
to lead diplomatically and also some of
this is first personal I mean who the
leader is it's not just some system
first personal leadership actually
matters we're not doing enough of that
certainly under Biden but we're
substituting for it by sending U.S
military capabilities to places like
Ukraine and and you know I I've been
pretty clear about this I would not send
another dollar to Ukraine in fact I
think it's in a front that we now
discover that we have American troops on
the ground in Ukraine so I think
intervention in parts of the world where
we have no direct National interest has
been a disaster I plot Trump for
actually defecting from a bipartisan
consensus around that for much of the
last 20 years he deserves credit for
that now I'm looking in other respects
to take the agenda much further than
Trump did to do it based on principles
but I want to recognize that was a
positive development in our foreign
policy as I see it that was the reason
live stream with Vivek ramaswamy who's
running for the Republican nomination
for president and has just published
capitalist punishment A Book Like
diatribe against ESG and other aspects
of what he considers woke capitalism if
you want to watch the full conversation
go here if you want to watch another
excerpt go here and come back next
Thursday every Thursday at 1 pm when
Zach wise Miller and I are talking to
somebody even more interesting than the
last week thanks for watching